[Music]
here's to nothing getting in the way of
our adventure Emily I can't go to South
America wait what also I'm breaking up
with you when like right now this is it
you're in the middle of it you don't
want to lose now I didn't know just stop
you poor thing you look awful thank you
I'll get you this it's a long hug all
right okay mom look how fun you were
pack your bags we're going to South
America absolutely not everybody knows
you need two years to plan a vacation
you don't do anything fun anymore that's
not true I protecting sculpting lessons
at the Y Dunham I told you I would not
acknowledge that that's frightening and
you made that okay here put this on what
is this a rape whistle this is a dog
whistle nah are you afraid I'm gonna get
raped by dogs it works why are you
dressed like a beekeeper son is
dangerous you so much on you put so much
I'm we're going aspect I'm definitely
not you're gonna miss this whole trip
everything shouldn't be so scary what I
need is an amazing adventure do you mind
if I join you hey that dude is [ __ ]
you what if I join you uh not you owes
me can you kind of beat it cuz you're a
distraction hey
our way the scenic route I'm gonna get
us out of this
I know a man he can take care of you
that's a sex slave mr. okay well those
people want young beautiful females just
to be safe I should maybe go kind of
hide in the jungle no no no your goofy
face will protect you I have some angles
that would like really surprise you
you